Many finteex are now under some kind of
pressure and have to collect money again
and there will probably be
a wave of consolidation,
i.e. finteex will be taken over,
maybe bought,
maybe
go bankrupt, but we have to
remember why so
much money flowed into finex in 2020 and 21  and
that's because we
simply have an extremely rigid
banking market in Europe where
the local champions in every single country
still haven't really made the leap into
the mobile age. We
have an industry that has extremely high barriers
to entry, i.e. with
regulation and technology  and we're talking
about customers who are very loyal,
which means that once you've
gained a bank customer in Europe,
they usually stay with you for the rest of
your life
and that's why I would say
we don't look so much at
other finteex  actually want
to offer a better alternative for the really big banks in Germany France Spain Italy